[Music]
hey mr. wonderful here you know one of
the things about doing television live
television particularly earning more
early morning television you got to get
up early I mean this is live TV very
often the show starts at 6:00 in the
morning so let's work backwards let's
say you're near the studio and you can
maybe walk there in a few blocks so you
got to get up it's sort of you know 4:00
4:15 you've got to read the notes
because the news changes overnight I
don't have to tell you that so here we
are it's real early and just got out of
the shower but also I got some fantastic
ask mr. wonderful questions like they
just keep getting better every week and
so trying to find time to fit these
puppies in because I want to answer them
so we're gonna do it right now
I got a shave so we're gonna do it while
I'm shaving and then we're gonna boot it
to the studio right afterwards so let's
let's start with hold on one second
there's our ears you know things you get
out of a shower you don't want to let
your beard go dry again this is much
tougher to shave it yeah and that's you
know TV you gotta look your best no
question about it so what I really liked
about this week is there's a lot of
career or any questions in there and I
think we've got to get into that because
a lot of a lot of you in your 20s are
trying to make a decision about
direction you know you're at a college
you're trying to pick a career maybe you
did arts need engineering maybe
something else in sciences but I got a
question from a 20 year old 20-something
year old named saffron now I love that
me I really love that mousse
I'll tell you why you probably don't
remember this artist mmm his name was
excuse me early morning
his name was Donovan this guy was a huge
hit psychedelic times and it's this is a
classic iconic hit
yes it's all just mad about saffron
saffron zhmed about me bump bump bump
huge hit future I don't know I get off
that derivative but it reminded me a
song when I heard saffron's question so
let's listen to her question first of
all let's get that done because I think
it's a good one
saffron what do you got let's hear it
I'm nearly 22 I almost have to meet two
people need some more advice regarding
my career constant business idea I
suffer from a lot of social anxiety so I
struggle a lot to the point where I
couldn't leave the house ideally I want
to work from home I've nearly completed
my bachelor's creative writing at
university I've also always wanted to
start a writing business as I enjoy
copywriting editing and managing social
media content I've had writing
experience for a few businesses and I
enjoyed writing to help others do you
think my writing degree is valuable
should I pursue a Master degree in the
morning is it worth getting more
certificates under my belt how do I go
about my writing career and how should I
start my writing business how do I go
about getting experience so saffron
there's a lot of issues there first of
all anxiety now you may be able to go
and get some help on that but great
artists sometimes are afflicted by
things like that anxiety attacks etc
it's just sort of how some people's
brains are wired but obviously the
concern and uncertainty about your
career because a writer is really not a
nine-to-five gig and there are many many
versions of what writers are in
television and films screen.if
screenwriters are different gig than
writing jokes for let's say a nighttime
show or even a ghost writer for books
now
I'm not going to discourage you in this
career because initially I always used
to think well the only thing you should
do is engineering because you're
guaranteed a job but I've learned that
writing and I work with many different
writers now including the ones the ghost
writers that work with me on
books the works of the people I work
with doing television the scripted
series is that sometimes I produce or
whatever I'm invested there is a very
big career in writing what matters about
it is are you any good and unfortunately
you can't determine that the market does
writers that are good get paid for their
work they actually have people that are
saying that's so good I can't do it
myself am willing to write you a check
and find you to continue to write for me
and it sounds like you might be that
kind of person I mean but the only way
to pursue this career is you gotta a get
out of the house you got to get rid of
that anxiety issue and you've got to go
peddle you you're the brand you're the
person you're the writer saffron is the
whole deal and saffron I gotta be honest
with you either you're going to make it
or you're not it's very binary I know
that sounds kind of you know callous but
you'll know in about 36 months in about
three years you'll either get gigs
you'll get involved in the writing
industry the word will get out about you
I mean that's you know I think about the
writers that I've actually written
checks as much as $50,000 to $100,000
people would help me write my books
luckily they've all been bestsellers so
the royalties come streaming and I
advance them fifty and then they recover
that and I have to pay them more as the
book sells but you'll know you'll just
will and the market will know and people
will talk about you I love that question
because I can feel your angst and and
the challenge of getting into the arts
but it doesn't mean it can't be a career
so saffron get out there and make it
happen that's what it's all about just
mad about saffron
I love that song okay let's move on and
you just little richer by the way the
water here is very hard
not easy to rinse okay next question
what do we got
oh I'm just I'm loving every week I keep
the international aspect of this is
absolutely fantastic
oh here's Erin ready what do we got hey
mr. wonderful Erin from Australia so I
mean what you've cool public housing I
guess I work for it be each which I
can't as my business I got five hundred
dollars saved in a girl somewhere I'm
just wondering if it's a good idea to
try and s that five hundred dollars into
something or do I just I tried going
into a bank account it's just too easy
to access the savings you can't believe
I gave you Chris from so I stopped doing
that and I've just been hoarding money
in my closet sir yeah that's a good idea
or a bad idea
I just want to notice what do I do with
my $500 thank you all right I love that
Erin is part of the gig economy he's
making a living as an uber eats driver
nothing wrong with that I mean it starts
to you just you learn early when
entrepreneurship is all about because
you know you're making all the money
based on your time you're moving around
and it's not a bad thing it's a good
starter position that's for sure because
it really makes you appreciate stability
but this idea of saving is important so
Aaron's got $500 you know and he's
debating what to do with it it's very
important that he's even thinking about
that that he's actually saying himself
I've got to start saving no matter what
I do I don't care for new bird driver
whatever you do you've got to take ten
if you can 15% and put it away now where
you put it away it was very interesting
because he's fighting with himself Heron
you got to put the money where it can
actually compound
I don't you're in Australia there's you
can definitely open a brokerage account
you can put it in there and invest it
probably at your age because you're
young stick it in the stock market it's
going to go up and it's going to go down
but generally speaking over a long
period of time you're going to make
six to eight percent on average maybe
seven which is much better than what
you're gonna get in that savings account
which is probably paying you less than
one percent but what I love about your
question is you're having a hard time
keeping your fingers out of it so don't
hide it under the mattress don't put it
in your pocket put it in an account it's
much harder to get it out of and that
means you can open up a brokerage
account with five hundred bucks you can
do it but you're absolutely right and
you brought up a great the biggest enemy
about investing in yourself is yourself
if you're weak you'll keep dipping into
your savings to buy stuff that you
shouldn't be buying because it's you
should let that money sit there and
compound in 30 years if it was
compounding at six or seven percent
Aaron's five hundred dollars plus all
the money he's going to continue to put
in there even if he stays as an uber a
driver for the next twenty years it's
going to be what you retire off that's
basically what it is I love the question
though but I Aaron's honest he knows
that he's his own worst enemy let's take
a quick toothpaste break here while we
get our next question and I got to keep
an eye on the time because I got to get
to the studio by six we know that next
question here is from Chris Chris what
do you got
[Music]
mmm mmm good question
now Chris is basically proven he's got a
business because he's got revenue that's
the first step
anytime you can be it six figures you
got something going on you're solving a
problem somebody and they're willing to
pay you for it how do you grow it that's
basically his question this is a big
decision and I'll tell you why growth
involves leverage leverage means more
people you have to start to manage
people
now some people are really good at it
and others large this is a skill set
that either you are born with or you
have to learn very quickly because in
growing a business you have to draw a
new talent in particularly it sounds
like in Chris's case to get more sales
so you've got to find great salespeople
you have to motivate them sales a very
hard job and you have to manage them and
you if the manage the business at the
same time and that my friends is what
entrepreneurship is all about I say to
Chris because he's got a business and
he's got six figures and he wants to get
to seven he's go for it buddy go for it
now is your life gonna be more fun and
easier than last year no it's gonna get
much harder but that's why they call it
work is it worth it oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's definitely worth it
you'll learn so much about managing
people and growing a business and
helping others grow their careers too
but the key to Chris's success is the
original six-figure sales whatever
you're doing Chris keep going because
you've got a business there my friend
let's take another question I like that
all right here we go we've got Garnett
Garnett what do you got for me I'm mr.
wonderful my name is Garrett I'm an
entrepreneur Gary seven years old I have
two businesses that aren't really
scalable but they make the money that I
need and so for that reason I wanted to
get into venture capital say my
portfolio and maybe find something that
is more shareable scalable my question
to you is do you think that there's a
type of field structure company or type
of risk amount of risk I should be
looking for for making my first
investment in venture capital I know
it's a very risky space so I am a bit
scared going in or maybe is there a
certain amount of my portfolio
percentage-wise it I should have a great
lesson like this any advice you have
would be extreme enough thank you
down Fang down Garret very stimuli risky
venture capital is you know I invest in
just from the shark tank thing in 3040
companies and maybe maybe a third of
them work out and shark tanks a very
powerful platform so we can help people
acquire our customers so it's great in
the adventure capital industry only one
in ten survive that means you've got a
90 percent failure rate over a long
period of time that's not good so I'm
not in love with you investing in
venture capital your young age when you
have money to invest at all if you're
going to do it Garet the only way is
you're the operator you invest in
yourself you invest in a business and
you try and make it because you're gonna
make a lot more money and solve for your
own career then investing in a whole
bunch you're going to need to invest in
ten to get one to work out and you're
going to lose money in 90% of them
that's terrible why not invest in
yourself at your age you know I remember
when I started out I couldn't sleep at
night as we're so worried you're always
in fear failure but that's a great
motivational aspect of being an
entrepreneur you start spending your own
money on yourself the best investment
ever in your life will always be
yourself particular if you understand
what
capitalist you know that you're taking a
risk if you're going to take a risk the
person to risk on is you so unless
you're gonna invest in yourself I'd
invest that money in the market on a
broad-based diverse portfolio and let it
make six or seven percent for you but
I'm not hot to trot to stick money in
the venture capital the time in your
life when you invest in venture capital
is when you're giving back after you've
made a ton of money then you say I can
put five to ten percent a whole bunch of
deals and help out the next generation
of entrepreneurs that's what I'm doing
but the real dough is sitting in a very
conservative portfolio that's how I buy
toothpaste
I gotta have cash that's how I eat and I
get it for my portfolio but anyways
thanks for that question let's take one
more here you know I'm keeping an eye on
the time for fifty by the way what are
we wearing today I'm going to be wearing
a grande Seiko red of course red band
it's a beautiful watch you know one
thing to understand about this thing is
that a lot of people think the Swiss
were the first to create the
complications and watches back in the
early 1900s say poverty it's not true it
was the Japanese they were the very
first to make very complicated movements
and they still do today you know people
think of a Seiko watch as an electric
quartz watch no there are master artists
within the grand Seiko organization that
make these incredibly complex movements
with beautiful this is actually poison
oak lacquer this beautiful red you don't
want to stick this on your tongue you
want to paint it onto a dial like this
and it's beautiful rose gold I love this
watch obviously I wear today it'll be
terrific on TV I'm getting you know
distracted here I love talking about
watches you know that let's get back to
the questions because there are some
great ones here this is from Michel
Michel my bell great Beatles song here
we go
hello Kevin my husband
we are preparing for his military
retirement a few years ago terrible
experience
trusting a family member in the
financial planning and investment space
what is the best way to bets are
verified legitimate financial advisors
thanks much Michelle
whoa that's an interesting one Michelle
you know very often people make the
mistake Michelle made and she'll never
make it again
you think the safest place to put your
money is with another family member no
you want an arm's length relationship
with an accredited advisor now many of
the services that are online provide
advisory information for free to you so
you can invest on your own but if you
require an advisory very often you
should have one particularly if you're
investing in fixed income like bonds and
Treasuries because they're not easy to
do on your own make it somebody that has
nothing to do with your family somebody
you can hire if you don't like the work
they're doing for you you can't fire
your brother or your sister or your
uncle they're still gonna be your family
member are gonna have bad blood between
them you don't want to do that now
luckily online if you're registered
representative if you're a broker for
example there's many online services
where you can go find out that person's
past I'm not trying to be negative but
obviously not everybody's great but 99%
of advisors are but you can go online
look up their name and find out who they
work for and find out what their if
there's ever been any complaints against
them and that's part of it what you have
to do to find an adviser I work with
many different advisors particularly in
fixed income there there have a long
track record of success I've known them
for years and years and years they work
for accredited firms and I can monitor
my county month but they are not my
family and they never will be thanks for
that question Michelle all right let's
move on here I'm looking at the time you
know one of the things you got you have
to watch out for when you're just a
little if you're a hair challenge like I
am you don't you want to avoid the Bozo
the Clown look where the hair sticking
out on the sides so I have this little
trimmer thing I could see a couple of
errand hairs they're gonna show up on
the camera
so I just do a little yeah there you go
probably need a haircut soon but anyways
looking good on camera you better think
about it but you don't want the bozo
factor you want to nip those little guys
in the bud you're sticking out there we
go
fantastic alright on to them another
question here listen this is a personal
grooming show you know last one which is
good because we're now yeah I got it I
got it I got to get going here this is
Rosalee Rosalee can I think of a song
for you Rosalee yes
hello mr. wonderful my name is Rosalie
Rivia and let me just say this you are
mr. wonderful you've got very soft heart
not not the wing it thank you Rosalie
the television mr. wonderful was
considered a hobby you guys use that
word a lot what is considered a hobby
also I had a patent I said to to Walmart
Walmart wanted a million of them I sent
them to the prototype they wanted a
million I did not have that to give to
them I thought they produce any license
but they don't so I have to find a
company and I really it's hard to it's
hard to find that company thank you very
much for this I truly appreciate it
how can I find the company thank you
alright Rosalie there's a bunch of
questions in there but this is great
there's many people in the in your
situation first of all what is a hobby
versus a business that's what the
Rosalie's first question in my
definition of that is if you start a
company start a business you start a
product you start something that you
think should make money if it's not
making money after three years that
never was a business it was a hobby and
you got to take it behind the barn you
got to shoot it unless you want to just
spend your time losing money because you
know great entrepreneurs and and I'm
telling you this happens to every
entrepreneur it certainly happened to me
not everything works out you got to try
things the first two may not work the
first three may not working then finally
you get a winner you keep trying that's
the whole idea that's the journey of
entrepreneurship but when you get a
product where Walmart a big-box retailer
says you know
I'd like to try that that sounds like a
good product Rosalie but we're not
manufacturers for Walmart
we're retailer we'll sell it online
we'll sell it in our stores you got to
bring us the product here's the things
you want to do if you're dealing with a
big box like that you do not want to
roll out your product to every store you
can't afford the cost of the inventory
and you don't know if it's going to sell
yet you want Walmart buyer to help you
with a test maybe 200 stores the way to
go because you're a female entrepreneur
that's a plus for you because we want to
help more women get into business and
certainly Walmart's a great corporate
client and customer for that and great
corporate supporter that way we do a lot
of business with my certain companies
with Walmart they're terrific they're
wonderful because they pay their bills
and they're very big and they can afford
to pay you but you're probably actually
getting into manufacturing is you're
probably going to have to go out shore
to build this to make it cheap enough to
sell I'm not saying you have to but you
may have to you need a partner
Rosalie you need to find a partner that
you trust that can help you actually go
through the logistics of building a
prototype getting a mold manufacturing
the first I don't know thousand pieces
and then sell them and once you find out
what customers say about them tweak the
product a little bit make it a little
better go through the process if
Walmart's gonna be your partner because
they love the product they'll work with
you and you'll slowly build this up but
you're not going to do it sitting at the
kitchen table unless you're doing
everything yourself it sounds like you
don't have the logistics skills and luck
don't feel bad about it I never did
either I found a partner early on that
could do that manufacturing logistics
inventory control I'm a sales guy I'm a
marketing guy I went to Bentonville I
met with buyers I've met with Walmart I
know the journey you're going through
and many other retailers to that matter
but it sounds like Rosalie you're gonna
need a partner look I loved the whole
ask mr. wonderful this week I love the
international aspect you know it's it's
fantastic to talk to people all around
the world it's a great tool a dialog and
if you don't mind the whole shaving
thing and everything but I just got to
find time in the day that's the problem
I'll answer these questions I want to do
it every week so you're gonna have to
bear with me as we do these journeys all
around the country I don't know where
I'll be next time but anyways it was
fantastic and remember all those
questions if you think about it we're
about savings of a career
about manufacturing it's they're all
inspirational in the sense that someone
wants to advance they want to start a
business
saffron wants to be a writer that's a
career thing the human condition is to
march forward not a destination
remember this it's a journey not every
day is great now I got to start my day
you know this is I got to put this on
and hit the road it's always I just love
choosing the first watch of the day
because it kind of sets the tone for the
rest of the hours ahead once it goes on
my business see you next time
that's enough
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
you